so nur charmant
ich habe da fängt nur die lorenz titel
im
kajak-einer sitzt einer der wenigen koch
persönlich sprechen weil das problem
ihrer speisen kann sonst irgendwie
schwarze seien die buchstaben ja das
habe ich im kopf und da hab ich gesagt
dass die asche nicht verantworten hat
und trotzdem wie gesagt der kunst sitzen
links und rechts sonst ist freilich das
habe ich auch aber dann stellt sich
heraus ihr geist wird das ändert
natürlich alles das ist bei mir sehr
schwer der horst vom jahres war es der
rucksack sagt und er ist fußballer hatte
sie nur schlimmer das würde seiner
spielvereinigung den ball vors tor wo
spielzüge inside schießens vereinsamte
und der currywurst fressen was hat ihnen
verzeihen was
jetzt haben wir zwei
herr thomas müller
fußball weltmeister vom fc bayern thomas
müller
das einzig erbringen sich wird vorher
gegen das essen also
was also ist
es unendlich eigentlich überall wo sie
wo sie maß ist wie vielleicht mehr hand
in kilometer oder ein kopf im friedrich
laker überhaupt nicht sagen sie würden
sich vorstellen vielleicht nach kann ins
kühlhaus stellen
wie kann ich helfen ja fußball gott ich
sage ihnen was ich finde nichts in ihrer
karte creme immer mantel mit ingwer
kartoffeln im innkreis rand im
wandelgang mit ingwer an ingwer mit ingo
überbacken sagen wir haben sich beim
schub erklären dass studieren dieses
kundenlösung der haut sie an der
kniescheibe aus
brauchen ich mag keinen haben sie nichts
ohne
ihn
ja vielleicht kartoffel mit reis und
nudeln deshalb gibt es dazu in
holland schon wieder in
der heimat
weil die platten ist aus holz jetzt hat
das aber genau benannt vielleicht
kosten für ganz hessen über in
supermärkten größter ganz so billig
der bestimmte rosinen supermarkt der
billig sei es wenn aber dann habe ich
wenigstens was zu messen